live look this morning at mccarran
airport it's obviously dark so you can't
tell but there you can see the tower in
the middle of your screen man it was a
frustrating weekend for southwest
airlines passengers and this morning
many customers are still waiting to see
if they can go home southwest airlines
canceled nationwide more than 1800
flights all over the weekend hector
mejia live this morning at mccarran
airport with the latest on possible
delays and just trying to get through
tsa hector good morning
yeah good morning it's that bad word you
don't want to hear when you're about to
fly out canceled about 30 flights
canceled in fact this morning out of
mccarran most of those southwest airline
flights the airline said it's all due to
air traffic management program and
severe weather in other parts of the
country but others point to a worker
shortage we found frustrated and
stranded passengers here at baggage
claim not just yesterday but this
morning as well those left behind said
they were not able to get flights home
until at least tomorrow that's tuesday
and what's worse is other airlines are
booked solid or offering new flights for
triple the plot the price
oh man to put it lightly it's torture i
mean i hate to complain because i'm sure
things are worse for others but i mean
southwest obviously canceled flights
last minute
i guess they couldn't get
crew in
some say they were on hold for several
hours that passenger you just heard from
jeremy wash said the earliest flight he
could get to pittsburgh was not until
thursday so he booked a flight for one
stay over to go to cincinnati and his
plan is to drive to his destination
he said to solve this to solve the
problem southwest offered a 200 voucher
and passengers said they tried to take a
rental car but that was also a struggle
we actually talked with one man who said
he had to wait 15 hours here at mccarran
just to get a rental car to get to
phoenix reporting live from mccarran
hector mejia live local now